je pense que le le vote s'il était
positif
si on a la discussion ce qui est pas
encore complètement acquis ce vote
répondra à une atteinte populaire
extrêmement forte parce qu'en fait on
n'a pas voté sur le projet de loi il y a
eu la motion censure ça porte sur
l'article 7 c'est-à-dire sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite il y a une atteinte
extrêmement forte et il y a eu ce qu'on
appelle indemnité démocratie dans la
mesure où ce projet de loi n'a pas
abouti véritablement à un vote sur son
contenu là on pourrait avoir un vote sur
un article du projet de loi qui est sans
aucun doute l'article plus important et
c'est très attendu par les organisations
syndicales et puis il y a un
mécontentement terrible dans le pays et
je crois que c'est aussi une dimension
symbolique et ensuite ça mettrait le
Sénat bien sûr face à ses
responsabilités donc vous n'êtes pas
dupe justement pour reprendre le mot du
fait que cette proposition de loignant
peut-être pas jusqu'au bout mais
symboliquement si l'assemblée assembler
voter contre vous diriez ce serait
important pour nous ce serait important
pour les adversaires peu importe ensuite
disons que si l'assemblée votée cette
proposition de loi pour supprimer cet
article cet article 7 c'est vrai que ça
aurait un impact considérable et je
dirais que ça alimentait ça alimente le
mouvement social qui n'est pas terminé
on verra ça le 6 juin il y a une
manifestation on rappelle contre la
réforme des retraites mais quand même le
gouvernement Elisabeth borne a dit la
semaine dernière que cette proposition
emploi est inconstitutionnelle il n'est
pas possible de supprimer 15 à 18
milliards de recettes sans compenser par
quoi compensez-vous ces pertes de
recettes
j'irai d'abord quels honte de tenir de
tels propos on a une fois par un groupe
parlementaire on a une journée qu'on
appelle notre niche parlementaire pas
une fois pas une fois une proposition de
loi a été re monter au nom du soi-disant
article 40 en disant que ça crée des
dépenses supplémentaires mais y compris
les députés de la majorité actuelle ont
déposé plusieurs propositions de loi qui
impliquaient une des pince moi-même lors
du manque d'apprécie d’inger j'ai réussi
à faire voter l'augmentation des
retraites agricoles il est bien
évidemment si on m'avait opposé
l'article 40 cette proposition de loi
d'augmentation des retraites agricoles
il y en a même eu deux une pour les
chefs d'exploitation une pour les
conjoints collaborateurs conjoint
collaboratrice pour l'essentiel si on
m'avait opposé l'article 40 on n'aurait
pas dit je vous repose une question
quand même dans le texte quelles sont
les compensations financières à ces
pertes budgétaires les compensation
financières je précise que en début de
l'année on a voté un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dans
lequel il y avait pas la loi retraite il
y avait pas la retraite et c'était
équilibré donc les compensations
financières pour comme dans toutes les
propositions de loi sont gagées par la
taxe sur le tabac comme dans toutes les
positions et c'est ensuite au
gouvernement de dégager les recettes oui
enfin soyons précis parce que vous savez
quand il y a quand c'est flou il y a un
loup hein
la démocratie pour moi elle n'a pas de
loup alors elle n'a pas de loupe
d'ici à quelques années ça ferait une
augmentation du tabac combien si vous
êtes rigoureux et vous l'êtes André ça
c'est pas une argument c'est un artifice
c'est un artifice que la majorité c'est
de mettre dans les têtes moi je suis
pour la séparation des pouvoirs j'estime
qu'on peut au moins une fois dans
l'année porter des propositions de loi
et quand on vient de ne pas nous amuser
avec des artific pour que la proposition
de l'homme n'arrive pas à discussion il
y a une espèce de grande mentale que
l'on met aujourd'hui dans la tête des
journalistes de crampes mentales en
disant en disant qu'il y a pas les
recettes et tout ça les recettes au
gouvernement des trouvées il fait
suffisamment de cadeaux suffisamment de
cadeaux au plus riche quand on regarde
notamment le montant de dividendes dans
ce pays on aura les recettes on les
trouvera si à la volonté politique le
gouvernement avait le cerveau des
journalistes je dis qu'aujourd'hui
je le dis aujourd'hui on essaie de faire
monter cette idée que cette proposition
de loi ne s'inscrit pas dans la
Constitution qui a pas de recette je
m'en ce qui me concerne je suis pour la
séparation des pouvoirs une fois dans
l'année on peut porter des propositions
de loi et c'est un artifice
anti-démocratique de s'y opposé alors
c'est une honte à vous dire l'argument
du gouvernement va aller plus loin avec
vous pourrez chez boucher bonjour
soyez les bienvenus
vous dites que ce serait pas
démocratique finalement si s'il n'y
avait pas de débat sur cette proposition
de loi est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a peur du débat ou ou pire
peur du vote
je pense que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
il utilise une balance Roberval il
essaie de soupeser quel serait les
conséquences
du vote de cette proposition de loi et
quelle serait les conséquences de
s'arranger pour que ça arrive pas en
débat je crois que louvermont
aujourd'hui à cette obsession que cette
proposition de loi ne soit pas votée
parce que c'est alimenterait le
mouvement social donc il met tout en
œuvre tout en œuvre pour que le débat
n'arrive mais ça veut dire que vous vous
pensez que ce texte peut être voté qui
peut passer ici à l'Assemblée nationale
je pense que le texte peut voter ne
serait-ce que par une décision
d'abstention collective par exemple des
républicains je pense qu'il a toutes les
chances de voter parce que s'il avait
aucune chance d'être voté est-ce que
vous pensez que le gouvernement sera
aussi fébrile que robergé s'exciterait
comme elle s'excite quand on est serré
de convaincre l'opinion publique ce que
cela n'a pas de sens qu'il y a pas les
recettes c'est bien qu'un risque réel
qui passe sinon il y aura pas il y
aurait pas de ce mouvement s'excite bien
sûr qu'elle s'excite elle s'excite de
façon phénoménale j'ai vu à la dernière
conférence des présidents ou notamment
elle a d'ailleurs commun une erreur elle
a dit c'est du droit coutumier que l'on
puisse présenter des propositions de loi
qui ne soit pas soumise à l'article 40
or le droit coutumier dans la hiérarchie
des valeurs je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est admis dans la mesure où
justement ces deux droites la présidente
alors l'usage veut d'ailleurs que le
président de la commission des finances
statue sur cet article 40 sur
l'irrecevabilité d'un texte est-ce que
pour vous la majorité a les moyens de
contourner la décision actuelle j'irai
d'abord que la recevabilité a été acté
par le bureau de fait puisque les deux
représentants du bureau qui sont chargés
chaque semaine de décider de la
recevabilité de d'une proposition de loi
on dit qu'il y avait la recevabilité il
y a pas de problème là-dessus ensuite
il y a toujours possibilité
effectivement n'importe quel moment on
peut saisir mais c'est le président de
la commission des finances c'est le
rapporteur général moi je pense c'est
plutôt le président de la commission des
finances
le levier nécessaire pour que la
discussion n'est pas lieu je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont sortir du chapeau donc
éventuellement le débat pourrait ne pas
avoir lieu
j'espère que non alors j'espère qu'il
aura lieu
Coquerel et les filles qui est
effectivement présent la commission des
finances et que c'est un membre de la
majorité qui est rapporteur du projet de
loi voilà pour voir un petit peu
effectivement les enjeux
le président des commissions des
finances qui prenait la décision alors
on va se mettre dans l'hypothèse ou le
texte est bien débattu dans l'hémicycle
le groupe Renaissance est prêt à faire
de l'obstruction est-ce que c'est pas de
bonne guerre compte tenu de l'attitude
de la gauche pendant la discussion de la
réforme des retraites
je pense que faire de l'obstruction sur
un texte de la niche annuel d'un groupe
parlementaire
c'est pas très bien venu
dans le cas de la séparation des
pouvoirs c'est pas le pouvoir législatif
qu'on dispose véritablement en toute
indépendance par rapport au poids
exécutif un groupe parlementaire là une
fois par an et c'est vrai que là aussi
il y a une forme de
presque dire aussi de droit coutumiers
que dans les niches parlementaires on
laisse on laisse du droit coutumier on
laisse c'est assez bas dans la
hiérarchie des normes non pas tant que
ça on laisse les projets les
propositions de leur discussion ont
aussi de on y a de nombreux exemples y
compris de c'est extra ultra majoritaire
en plus des textes de loi qui ont été
portés y compris d'ailleurs je crois pas
européen j'ai on parle d'un texte de loi
sur le milieu vieillir qui engendre qui
a été voté et qui engendre plusieurs
milliards dépenses supplémentaires il y
a pas eu de problème ma proposition de
loi met deux propositions de loi lors du
mandat précédent sur les retraites
agricoles et bien
engendrer des dépenses qui étaient
estimées
de l'autre mais deux propositions de loi
certes elles ont été réduites mais elles
ont été votées et le gouvernement a levé
le gage que j'avais mis dans la
proposition de loi je pense je pense
qu'on a écouté on a une cinquième
République on a une
[Musique]
groupe la gauche démocratique
on a on avait un texte sur la DGF vous
avez l'obstruction a été faite par des
ministres c'est à dire que Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire
on parlait une heure environ pour
retarder les débats
donc ça peut avoir de tout d'accord
qu'ils sont capables de tout et quand il
s'agit dégrabouillés l'opposition et le
pouvoir législatif et ben il sorte
toutes les armes qui peuvent trouver
alors si c'est voté en première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale ce texte malgré
tout malgré le la volonté d'écrabouiller
qu'est-ce que ça change est-ce que vous
demandez la suspension de la réforme des
retraites qui a été votée qui doit
s'appliquer au 1er septembre la
suspension des décrets d'applications
qu'est-ce que vous faites ce que ça
représenterait quand on a vu la
mobilisation qu'il y a eu dans le pays
quand on voit qu'il y a qu'il y a une
opposition
ultra majoritaire dans le pays quand on
voit que syndicale l'Inter syndical
reste unie continue à manifester ça
serait le cas le 6 juin quand on voit
que le mécontentement le rejet de ce
projet de loi reste entier reste entier
je crois que carburant de manifestations
un sacré carburant qu'on mettra dans le
moteur pour continuer à se bagarrer
contre ce projet loi demandé son retrait
et ensuite il partira au Sénat bien
évidemment le Sénat prendra ses
responsabilités je suis pas là la
réforme sera entrée en application le
1er septembre
oui le temps que la niche arrive au
Sénat on sait que très compliqué en plus
revenir sur la réforme sera suspendue et
qu'elle n'entre pas comme le CP ce que
je souhaite l'exigence que l'on peut
avoir c'est que si c'est voté à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est que le
gouvernement est bien suspendra cette
réforme je crois que ça serait la
moindre des choses c'est que le un bol
sera tellement fort que ce qui est
manuel Macron a refusé depuis des mois
malgré 14 manifestations il le ferait
maintenant mais vous croyez vraiment ce
que c'est
vous croyez vraiment ce que ça rapporte
moi j'ai pas baissé les uns je pense
qu'on peut encore obtenir le retrait de
cette réforme j'en suis persuadé
à votre honnêteté vraiment vous croyez
vraiment ce que vous dites alors
par exemple avec les journalistes je ne
fais jamais de ouf avec journaliste car
je m'exprime j'exprime ce que je pense
ça fait depuis que je suis lu et ça fait
longtemps sans cumulent tout ça doit
faire plus d'un siècle un depuis que je
suis élu j'ai su réessayé de m'exprimer
en toute franchise je ne fais pas de
cinéma
[Musique]